ich habe nämlich vorhin deswegen da
möchte ich nämlich wirklich darauf zu
sprechen kommen das haben wir auch
nämlich ganz eifrig diskutiert dass wir
diesen entschluss zu sagen ich trete
kürzer was ich eingehen vorhin gesagt
habe was sie gemacht haben
er fand mir so mutig was man war das für
sie auch bar oder war ihnen das bewusst
dass sie gesagt haben okay ich mache das
jetzt endlich traue mich jetzt das zu
sagen
also ich weiß gar nicht ob das mutig ist
ich habe einfach irgendwann gemerkt dass
ich mich völlig verschleiß und ich meine
ich bin in die politik gegangen um was
zu bewegen ich möchte menschen erreichen
münchen überzeugen
und ich finde auch nach wie vor also das
ist ja unverändert so dass wir ein
besseres land haben könnten wenn wir es
anders gestalten
aber wenn man dann irgendwann merkt man
ist in einer funktion wo man unglaublich
viel kraft dafür verwendet dinge zu tun
die eigentlich nichts bewirken also die
keine provision bürgerrat wirkung haben
sondern wo man wirklich immer nur müde
und müder und müder wird dann wird man
ja auch schlechter mann ist hat ja auch
weniger zeit neue ideen zu entwickeln
dann muss man irgendwann sagen okay
dafür bin ich aber nicht in die politik
gegangen ich wollte nicht nur
funktionieren ich wollte was erreichen
hat man jetzt vielleicht sind männer
robuster das kann sein wobei ich sagen
muss in dem punkt habe ich tatsächlich
auch respekt vor frau merkel also so
robust ich sehe also was sie jetzt seit
den ganzen jahren an anderen terminen an
ein drucker an dingen wegsteckt also das
können auch offensichtlich frauen das
ist sehr unterschiedlich aber kann schon
sein dass bei männern oft ganz andere
fragen gestellt dass sie bei uns frauen
ist es direkt zum druck also dieses
diese fragen schon frau würde ich wie
schaffen sie das mit haushalt und
kindern und arbeit diese frage hat mein
ex mann nicht einmal in seinem leben
bekomme nicht ein einziges mal und das
impliziert ja schon dass ich es schaffen
muss diese frage ja ich glaube einer
frau guckt man auch mehr hin wenn sie
müde aussieht und sie frage dann auch
dazu befragt wie sie sehen aber schlecht
aus ich habe also nicht ich habe ja
selber mein mann ist ja auch politiker
und ich glaube es war noch nicht so
häufig dass er gefragt wurde wenn er
müde war ob er müde aussieht also weil
man bei frauen natürlich auch viel
stärker auf diese äußerlichkeiten
also das ist schon eine andere also das
ist eine andere wahrnehmung öffentlich
[Musik]